This looks fake,
but it's real.
This is real money I got from the US Mint.
It's the government organization that's responsible
for printing all the money that we use.
This is called uncut currency.
It's legal money.
This has 16 bills at $2 a piece.
Yes. Two dollar bills still exist.
So technically,
this sheet is worth $32.
In fact, I should be able to hand this to any business.
Than they should accept it as a legal form of payment.
It has real value.
Check this out.
This note is legal tender for all debts,
public and private.
It's real money.
But think about it.
Before the ink touched this page,
it wasn't worth anything at all.
As soon as the Mint stamps this paper
with these markings,
it suddenly has value.
That's crazy.
What's crazier to think about
is what people do for these pieces of paper.
People cheat each other.
They lied to each other.
They even killed each other over this paper.
Literal paper.
I know what you're thinking.
It's a representation of value in the real world.
Like a deed is a piece of paper
that represents property.
Or a carno represents the car.
So what is this piece of paper represent? Gold,
oil, diamonds?
Something in the real world? No,
it represents the faith and credit of the US government.
For whatever that's worth.